gab es ja im verlauf dieses krieges auch
kritik an deutschlands festhalten an
russischem gas bei den sanktionen sei
man nicht konsequent genug und nun kommt
da ein wirklich spektakuläres
politisches fehler ein geständnis nicht
von irgendjemandem sondern vom ersten
mann im staate dem bundespräsidenten
frank walter steinmeier nämlich hier
sehen sie unsere heutige seite 1 der
bild zeitung und das hat er gesagt unter
anderem meine einschätzung war dass
wladimir putin nicht den kompletten
wirtschaftlichen politischen und
moralischen ruin seines landes für
seinen imperialen waren in kauf nehmen
würde da habe ich mich wie andere auch
gewitzt und dass man nicht das einzige
fehler ein geständnis was er gemacht hat
darüber müssen wir auf jeden fall reden
im studios ralf schuler leiter der
parlamentsredaktion schon morgen ralf
erhoben fehler eingestehen kennt man von
unseren politikern jetzt eigentlich
nicht so kommt nicht so häufig vor umso
höher einzuschätzen ist dieses fehle ein
geständnis oder späte erkenntnis kann
nie schaden das problem an diesem
eingeständnis ist dass er gnadenlos
recht hat und er hätte es früher wissen
können man muss sich klar machen frank
walter steinmeier war
kanzleramtsminister unter gerhard
schröder er war später außenminister und
spätestens seit der annexion der krim
war eigentlich klar dass putin im
übertragenen sinne keine gefangenen
macht also es war eigentlich immer klar
dass man mit einem überzeugungstäter mit
einem eher getriebenen nationalistischen
großmacht politiker anders umgehen
musste als mit einem rationalen
dealmaker wie man es in der westlichen
welt kennt und das muss man eigentlich
schon sagen so ein schuldeingeständnis
jetzt vom bundespräsidenten dem ersten
mann im staate gut und schön aber was
folgt daraus und man hat schon den
eindruck er spricht immer von wir wir
haben fehler gemacht ich weiß nicht wen
er damit meint die bevölkerung in
deutschland hat sicherlich weniger
fehler gemacht vielleicht meint er die
kanzlerin die die russlandpolitik her
geprägt hat aber die politische kultur
geht eigentlich auch seit jahren bei uns
vor die hunde das muss man so dramatisch
mal sagen man räumt fehler ein und macht
dann einfach weiter und wenn jemand der
verantwortung für ein ganzes land für
das stärkste industrieland in europa
trägt und ein land in eine falsche
richtung steuert wo hinterher alle wir
jetzt die folgen tragen wir abhängig
sind von der energie weil ganz europa in
geiselhaft genommen wird von unserer
energieabhängigkeit in der russland
politik dann müssen einfach konsequenzen
folgen das fragen könnten diese
konsequenzen aussehen das fragt man sich
natürlich jetzt so ein schuljahr
angestellten ist es ja schön und gut
sagt sie selbst aber was muss jetzt
passieren ja also zumindest eine
schonungslose aufarbeitung das klingt
immer ein bisschen harmlos ein rücktritt
frank walter steinmeiers würde jetzt
nichts ändern die kanzlerin ist nicht
mehr im amt aber man muss sich wirklich
klar machen welche fehler man da
begangen hat man hat in verhandlungen
mit einem wirklich erkennbar nicht
gewählten verhandlungspartner
immer wieder zugeständnisse gemacht in
der hoffnung er würde sich dann
besänftigen lassen ist begann mit den
mit dem einmarsch in georgien in
südossetien und abchasien es gab in
bergkarabach einmärsche von von russland
die immer dazu führten dass der westen
sagte ja was können wir denn machen um
die sache zu befrieden am ende bekam er
immer belohnungen für
völkerrechtswidrige handlungen und
spätestens nach der annexion der krim
war klar dass er nicht so schnell dort
wieder ausgehen würde die kanzlerin hat
intern mal gesagt ich habe niemandem so
viel zeit gewidmet so viele
verhandlungsmöglichkeiten gegeben wie
putin und niemand hat mich so oft
belogen und betrogen das konnte man sehr
lange wissen das konnte man dann sehr
lange wissen sei man noch mal ein
bisschen bei der rolle von angela merkel
wollte mir sie lenski hat sie ja auch
direkt in einem statement gestern
angesprochen hat sie eingeladen nach
butter hat gesagt also hier sie und
nicolas sarkozy sollten sich mal
anschauen was sie in ihrer jahrelangen
russlandfreundlichen politik jetzt
angerichtet haben kann man ihr das
wirklich so direkt vorwerfen siehst du
das ähnlich ja man muss halt die emphase
des präsidenten kann man emotional
verstehen er selbst ist ja noch im
letzten jahr bei angela merkel gewesen
und hat sie besucht da war die tonlage
eine andere
natürlich gehen da jetzt die die nerven
durch wenn man in china sitzt und
beschlossen wird das ist völlig klar
gleichzeitig muss man halt sagen die
blutigen folgen dieser politik sind ist
dieser krieg also angela merkel hat
immer nicht nur in mit bezug auf
russland sondern auch mit china darauf
gesetzt dass ist multilateral das heißt
in der gemeinschaft der völker
einigungen deals und verträge gibt die
dann eingehalten werden wenn man aber in
einen vertragspartner hat der die
verträge motorisch nicht einhält der
minsker vaters nie eingehalten worden
dann muss man die stärke des rechts die
sie immer beschworen hat damit
durchsetzen dass man auch der
militärisch politisch wirtschaftlich
stärkere ist hat sie sich aktuell
eigentlich mal geäußert so diesen
vorwürfen zum konflikt allgemein und
wenn nicht sollte sie das mal tun das
sollte sie dringend tun sie wird wissen
warum sie es nicht tut sie hat sich
gestern auch auf bild anfrage dazu
eingelassen dass die bilder ihr nahe
gehen und dass sie gleichwohl das hat
selena angesprochen an der entscheidung
die ukraine 2008 nicht in die nato
aufzunehmen festhält und sie nach wie
vor für richtig hält das würde mich auch
wundern wenn sie einen so kapitalen
fehler eingestanden
das problem ist dass wir alle nicht
wissen ob der krieg vermeidbar gewesen
wäre wenn die ukraine
in der nato gewesen wäre trotzdem müsste
sie sich eigentlich dazu äußern denn sie
hat die russlandpolitik geprägt in den
letzten 16 jahren und trotzdem dass es
eben angesprochen spüren wir weiterhin
geld in die kriegskasse von wladimir
putin sollten wir nicht jetzt endlich
sagen gas und öl stoppt aus russland
wäre das nicht der wirkliche logische
schritt
das klingt natürlich konsequent ich habe
zweierlei bedenken einerseits
unterschätzen wir die komplexität der
energieströme die das gas nimmt bis in
die lebensmittelindustrie hinein wir
müssten die ganzen branchen die sehr
energieintensiv sind müssen wir
abschalten müssten versuchen wie wir die
arbeitslosigkeit der mitarbeiter auf
abfedern das würde uns in ein neues
wirtschaftliches
schweres fahrwasser bringen das ist also
nicht also die folgen sind schon da das
ist so als wenn sich ein patient einen
tropf auszieht um den arzt zu bestreifen
sehr sehr schwierig muss man diskutieren
was da geht und was nicht geht die an
das andere bedenken was ich habe
überzeugungs getriebene narzissten wie
putin wie erdogan oder assad hungert man
nicht aus sie werden bis zur letzten
patrone kämpfen sie werden notfalls ihr
volk auspressen also nationalismus ist
eine stärkere droge als unser geld wir
denken da oftmals in kategorien die wir
kennen und ich fürchte die rechnung wird
nicht aufgehen
ralf schuler dankeschön für eine ganz
aktuelle entscheid wir schauen wie es
weitergeht dann greift